اعلنت شركه الوطنيه للاسكان في السعوديه
عن اكبر ضاحيه سكنيه جديده في مدينه
الرياض وهي ضاحيه الفرسان والمرحله
الثانيه من ضاحيه خزنه لتصبح اكبر معروض
عقاري في العاصمه الرياض وستوفر الثمانين
الف واحده سكنيه وتاتي ضحيه الفرسان على
مساحه 35 مليون متر مربع في شمال شرق
الرياض تستهدف بناء اكثر من خمسين الف
واحده سكنيه فيما تقع المرحله الثانيه من
ضاحيه خزام في شمال العاصمه الرياض على
مساحه تتجاوزوا واحدا 20 مليون متر مربع
وتستهدف بناء
30,000 وحده سكنيه
استديوهاتنا رئيس التنفيذي للشركه
السعوديه للاسكان محمد البوطي حياك الله
استاذ محمد
خزام وضاحيه فرصه مش اهم التفاصيل المحيطه
بهذين في هذا التوقيت تحدي
الحقيقه في هذا المقام لان نتقدم بشكل
جليل لسمو سيدي ولي العهد على الدعم
الكبير والمستمر
لمنظومه الاسكان بشكل كبير نحو تحقيق
مستدفات رؤيه 20 30 همم واللي الحمد لله
الدعم الكبير وصلنا الى النسبه او تجاوز
ال 60% في 2020 ان شاء الله الى تحقيق
النسبه المستهدفه في العشرين 30
طبعا اييه بالنسبه لمدينه الرياض وزي ما
ذكر معالي وزير الشؤون البلديه والقرويه
والاسكان الاسبوع الماضي في منتدى
المستقبل عقار تحدث عن المعروضه العقاري
في مدينه الرياض اقل من البطوله بالضبط
وذكر انه مع الوزير الدعم الكبير والتمكين
من الدوله ومن الحكومه يد الله بتخصيص
اراضي همم حقيقه كبيره لضخ معروضه كبيره
اليوم احنا في الوطنيه الاسكان في الشركه
الوطنيه للاسكان يعني نطلق او نعنا لهم عن
مشروعين همم في مدينه الرياض فيها معروض
عقاري كبير همم يتجاوز 80,000 وحده سكنيه
ستساهم في في في توازن همم
كثير من الاسعار وايضا ستخدم شريحه كبيره
همم من المستفيدين طبعا احنا اليوم في في
هذه المشروعين نخدم جميع الشرائح همم
في في في مشاريع راح تكون نوعيه متكامله
الخدمات
وان شاء الله راح تطلب
كبير في مدينه الرياض ممتاز ايضا الوزير
يمكن في اللقاء الاخير اتكلم بالاضافه لما
ذكرتها عن المعرض والطلب عن مشكله ارتفاع
الاسعار ما زالت يجيء المستمره ويمكن
اكثر من قدره الناس والمواطنين على التملك
يعني بالنسبه للاسعار الحريف
كيف راح يتم التاث
والمتوسط الاسعار فيها كيف حيكون طب يعني
احنا لما نصمم المشاريع ونعمل على هذا
المشاريع يكون عندنا دراسه للشريحه
المستهدفه همم بالذات شريحه المستحيل
الدعم السكني والمسكن الاول ولدينا دراسه
من واقع من واقع البيانات الموجوده يتم
تصميم المنتجات بما يوافق القدرات
الشرائيه المستفيدين بحيث يكون عندنا يعني
نلبي طلب لكل الشرائح حسب البيانات من
المستفيدين المستحقين للدعم السكنيه همم
حجم المشروعين همم
المشروع اولا انه ان اسعاره ديت سكينه
تكون همم ذات جوده عاليه وباسعار مناسبه
توافق رغبات المستفيدين وايضا لانه في
الجانب همم اللي جوده الحياه والمرافق همم
في هذه المجتمعات اليوم مثل هذا المشروعين
همم النسبه التخطيطيه فيها والمسطحات
الخضراء مدروسه همم بالعكس يمكنها يعني في
في صمامات تكون توافق معي جوده الحياه
عندنا في مشروعنا في شمال الرياض او في
المشروعين اجمالي الحدائق مساعده حدائق
يتجاوز سته ملايمات المربع همم المشروع
يعني في في مشروعنا في شمال الرياض في همم
واحد من اكبر حدائق مدينه الرياض حديقه
العالم سته كيلومترات او 7 كيلو مترات همم
كل هذا انا اخذها في الاعتبار وايضا ما
تؤثر على اشعار وحدات سكينه بحيث انه يكون
الحقيقه متكامل الخدمات وايضا همم متميز
همم يقلل من اهم الخدمه
احنا في المشروعين هذه احنا في الحقيقه
تبنا مدن
المشروع الواحد يعادل تقريبا ثمانيه الى
تسعه احياء من احياء مدينه الرياض فكل
الخدمات سواء مجمعات تجاريه من الاسواق من
مدارس وخلافه تكون في في هذه الاحياء بحيث
انه تقلل الحركه حركه ساكنين
بشكل كبير خارج هذا الاحياء او هذا
المجتمعات ما هذا طبعا انتقال اذا كان
هناك عمل خارج همم
الحيه او المشروع همم حركه المشاهده
مدروسه بشكل كبير بحيث انه ممكن التنقل
داخل الحي بشكل كبير يعني
ما يكون استخدام همم السياره للمرافق
القريبه او حتى المدارس كل هذه تاخذ في
الاعتبار في في تصميم هذا الاحياء همم
بحيث انه ما تكون تفكيره في تقديم فقط
وحدات سكنيه همم واسعار من ايضا حتى جوده
حياه
اقل من السوق يعني
لا تقل همم اشعار وحدات عن همم 20 ل 25%
اقل من اسعار المحيطه واحيانا تتجاوز ذلك
في الغالب يعني تكون هذه الاشعار السهدفه
في الغالب تكون اقل بكثير من الاشياء يعني
عندي متى راح يبدا العمل على المشروع همم
متى متوقع ان ينجز ان يتم على ارض الواقع
هنتكلم عن مشروع البيع على الخالق
كمان يعني هذين المشروعين همم كيف هيكون
شكلهم يعني بعد بعد التنفيذ ومتى وكيف
هتكون طريقه التقديم عليه جميل همم طبعا
احنا نعمل احنا في عجل مستمر يعني اليوم
في الشركه الوطنيه الاسكان اذا تكلمنا عن
مدينه الرياض اا احنا اطلاقنا مشاريع
سابقه همم والجميله ان عندنا مشاريع في
شمال الرياض في الشرق ايضا عندنا في جنوب
الرياض همم مجموعه كبيره من المشاريع
عليها همم
هم الاكبر حتى على مستوى المملكه او قد
يكون حتى على مستوى المنطقه بالحجم
الاماراتي يتجاوز يمكن 60 ملي ريال وهي
مشاريع يعني كبيره جدا ايضا نعمل على ان
تكون هناك رحله امين سهله وسالتها
للمستفيدين من حيث همم التقديم او الطلب
همم وربط المستفيدين مع المطورين احنا
نعمل بشكل كبير همم مع المطورين العقارين
في تقديم هذا الوحدات السكنيه وايضا
المستفيدين يتقدمون عن طريق همم منصه
سكنيه وتطبيق سكني بالامكان اطلعي على كل
المشاريع والحجز بطريقه سهله الى التمويل
الكتروني عن طريق البنك ممكن يكون عن طريق
التطبيق او زيارات مركز سكن الشامل او
زياره مركز المطور بطريقه سهله تسهل على
المستفيدين همم الرابط مع الجهات التمويل
وايضا معرفه الاسعار والتصاميم والتقديم
على الطلب والشراء طبعا همم في الغالب
احنا نكون همم من تاريخ الى الى التسليم
متوسط 36 شهر ثلاث سنوات الى التسليم
والعجله مستمر
المشروعين بالضبط
في الرياض طبعا المشروع الاول جمعيه
الوحدات السكنيه
المرحله الثانيه احنا بدانا المرحله
الاولى تقريبا على مساحه عشر ملايين متر
بيعت بالكامل الحمد لله بدانا نسلم فيها
بدا التسليم فيها وزي ما قلت لك خزانات
المرحله الثانيه
وبيعت بالكامل بل انه بدا التسليم في بعض
مراحلها
اسعارها تبدا شقق طبعا تبدا تقريبا من
350,000 ريال واحنا نطلع الى البلل متوسط
هاي يمكن حدود
850,000 ريال هذا كان
متوسطين زي ما قلت لك نخدم اكبر شريحه
ممكن انا موجوده
على شريحه يعني واحده فاليوم راح تحصل
عندنا شرائح كثير جدا ولكن نركز على
الشريحه الاكبر اللي هي تقريبا بين تقريبا
حدود 350 4 في الحدود 900,000 هذه نركز
عليها ولكن كل الشرائح الثانيه موجوده هنا
بالاضافه هذا شيء مهم لانه المرافق او
الخدمات التجاريه والخلافه ايضا ماخوذه في
الاعتبار وبحيث ان يكون الحي مكتمل
الخدمات مكتمل المرافق همم يعني مراعي معي
جوده حياته هذه يمكن مهمه جدا تساعد
الساكنين انه يكون في حي متكامل
اقل سعر فيلا انت تقول لي 300 800 هذا
المتوسط
الاقل
خالد طبعا حسب المراحل بدايه تكون الاسعار
اقل وما يتقدم المشروع تكون ترتفع الاسعار
فين ما لها يعني ضبط محدث انا اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المعلومات رئيس تنفيذي
للشركه السعوديه شكرا